ربيع بعد عام على بدايه هذه الحرب كيف
يبدو التعاون العلمي بين روسيا وباقي
الدول تحديدا الغرب نعم حسن هي ستار من
حديد اسديل على روسيا العلميه منذ بدايه
الحرب على اوكرانيا لكن الترابط بين الدول
يعقد الامور فالبحث العلمي حاليا هو مجال
عالمي بامتياز بضعه ارقام للتاكد من ذلك
في فرنسا ثلثاء المقالات العلميه المنشوره
هي مقالات مشتركه مع باعي حيثينا من دول
اخرى من بينها طبعا روسيا ليس في فرنسا
فقط في الولايات المتحده مثلا وهي الرائده
في المجال العلمي اكثر من 40% من الابحاث
العلميه المنشوره هي نتاج تعاون دولي
النسبه ذاتها تقريبا نجدها في روسيا
العلوم اليوم حسنيه هي شبكه دوليه واي حرب
اي توتر في العلاقات بين الدول يؤثر على
التطور العلوم
ونسال بالضروره عن مظاهر ذلك ربيع لنبدا
باهم مجال للتعاون العلمي والظاهر للعامه
وهو مجال الفضاء افضل تجلياته طبعا محطه
الفضاء الدوليه منذ الايام الاولى للغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا وبعد اعلان الدول
الغربيه لحزمه عقوبات قاسيه على موسكو هدد
مدير الوكاله الروسيه للفضاء
هدد الدول الغربيه بشان تاثير العقوبات
على محطه الفضاء الدوليه ولمح بخطر سقوط
المحطه لكن في الصيف الماضي لم يبقى
ديمتري روجوزين في منصبه وتم تعويضه
على راسك واهم ما اعلنه بوريسوف هو نيه
موسكو وقفه استغلالها لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه بعد عام 2024 للتركيز على انشاء
محطه فضائيه روسيه 100% القرار سياسي
بامتياز لكن شدد على التزام روسيا
بتنفيذ التزاماتها اذن والتي اخذتها
تجاهها في المحطه وبالفعل رغم التوتر
والتهديدات تمت المهمات في محطه كما كان
مقررا لها وما زال قبل ساعات فقط حسنيه
اطلقت روسيا صاروخا سيوز وهو يحمل مركبه
خاليه فلتلتحموا بالمحطه الدوليه لماذا
لارجاع ثلاثه رواد فضاء عالقين على متن
المحطه بعد حادثه تسرب كبيره تعرضت لها
المركبه التي كان من المقرر ان تعود بهم
الى الارض رواد الفضاء الثلاثه العالقون
الى غايه سبتمبر المقبل هم روسيان وامريكي
روسيا وامريكي هم في مركب واحد كما ترين
حسنيه من الصعب وقف التعامل في برامج
الفضاء بين ليله وضحاها رغم الحرب وربيع
هل من امثله اخرى عن استمرار هذا التعاون
العلمي بين الدول بالرغم من الحرب نعم
حسنيه رغم انها تبقى امثله قليله هنا في
فرنسا مثلا يوجد اكبر مشروع علمي وتقني
وهندسي في العالم حاليا الا وهو مشروع
ايتيغ للاندماج
النوويجن الهدف انتاج طاقه نظيفه ولا
متناهيه في العقود المقبله روسيا مشاركه
في هذا المشروع الضخم مع اكثر من 30 دوله
اخرى كل دوله تساهم في المشروع اما
بالتمويل او التخطيط او تصنيع اجزاء من
مفعل الاندماج النووي هذا التعاون مستمر
فقبل عشره ايام فقط وصل الى موقع مفعل
ايتار جزء هام صنعته روسيا وارسلته يتعلق
الامر بملف كهرومغناطيسي ضخم يزن 200 طن
فقط عن تعاون علمي بين روسيا وشركائها
الدوليه نعم حسانيه لكن ذلك يتعلق بمشاريع
قائمه منذ مده توقيفها هكذا ليس بالسهل
تجليات وقف التعاون العلمي تخص اساسا كل
المشاريع المستقبليه التي لم تاد فعليا
بالعوده الى مجال الفضاء وجدت وكاله
الفضاء الاوروبيه
بعد وقف شراكتها مع نظيرتها الروسيه اذ لا
تتوفر السا على عدد كاف ومتنوع من
الصواريخ لنقل مركباتها ومصادرها الى
الفضاء هناك طبعا صواريخ اريانا الاوروبيه
لكن الجيل الجديد لاريان غير جاهز بعد
الاوروبيون كانوا يعتمدون على صواريخ سيوز
الروسيه كثيرا حاليا هم يتجهون نحو
الولايات المتحده نحو شركه سبيس اكس
الخاصه لمالكها ايلون ماسك لتعويض النقص
الحاصل لكن اقوى ضربه تلقتها الابحاث
الفضائيه الاوروبيه اثر الحرب الاوكرانيه
هي تلك التي تعرض لها برنامج اكزومارس في
كوكب المريخ برنامج اوروبي روسي كان سيطلق
الخريف الماضي موسكو كانت مساهمه بمركبه
انزال كانت ستحط وعلى متنها مسبار اوروبي
يحوم فوق سطح الكوكب الاحمر وقف التعاون
الاوروبي الروسي قضى على امال هذه المهمه
والتي تحاول وكاله ايسا انقاذها بايجاد
شركاء جدد ما سيكلف مليارات الدولارات
الاضافيه
من دون شك التصعيد من الجانبين يطرح
السؤال حول امكانيه عوده المياه الى
مجالها واستئناف التعاون العلمي بشكل عادي
كما كان في سابق عهده هذا مستبعد ما دامت
الحرب قائمه وما دامت سياسه بوتين على
حالها يصعب تصور رجوع المياه الى مجاريها
فالرئيس الروسي يحاول منذ سنوات حتى قبل
الحرب يحاول تسخير الجامعات الروسيه
والباحثين الروس لخدمه مشروعه السياسي
والفكري محاولات يستعمل فيها النظام
الروسي الترهيب والترغيب مثال على مع
بدايه الحرب على اوكرانيا قبل عام
ظهر نوع من التردد في الجامعات الروسيه
قبل ان يوقع غالبيه مدراء الجامعات
والمعاهد العلميه الروسيه ان يوقعوا رساله
دعم واضحه للعمليه العسكريه الروسيه هل
كان لهؤلاءك المدراء خيار بعدم التوقيع
على ايا كان لذلك رد فوري اذ اعلنت جل
الجامعات والمعاهد الاوروبيه والامريكيه
عدم خوضها في اي برنامج تعاون جديد مع
نظيراتها الروسيه لكن المفارقه المفارقه
هو اننا نعرف ان كثيرا من العلماء
والباحثين الروس لا يوافقون الكريم
مع بدايه الحرب وقع قرابه ثمانيه الاف
اكاديمي روسي عريضه تنتقد الحرب طبعا منذ
ذلك الوقت خفت تلك المعارضه الاكاديميه
بسبب المضايقات السياسيه والقمع والسؤال
السؤال الذي يطرح في الاوساط العلميه
الغربيه هو التالي كيف يمكن معاقبه النظام
الروسي دون الاضرار بالباحثين الروس الذين
لا علاقه بسياسات موسكو كيف يمكن ضرب
الكريم دون قطع التواصل مع المجتمع الروسي
المنفتح على العالم وعلى قيم مشتركه مثل
ما هو عليه اكاديميون روس هي فعلا معضله
حقيقيه مئات منهم غادروا روسيا للجوء الى
دول غربيه مع اعتبر فرار ادمغه جديد وواسع
في روسيا الخوف كل الخوف يبقى ان يتحول
المجال العلمي كمجالات اخرى الى ساحه
لتحالفات دوليه جديده تباعد بين العلماء
ونذكر بالصين الصين التي يريد رئيسها
علوما صينيه مستقله خالصه
شكرا جزيلا لك كازيمي الربيع و